what do you do during freshman week I
mean are they even around isn't this
must be some like huge party they do
like this and stuff let's go back let's
do a bet yeah yeah yeah you're me
whoever has sex first gets 50 quid
that's what I think ready yeah that's
why I bet 50 quid oh hey Peter Peter
Peter Peter
Pete Peter hey Joanne sky filthy dukes
do you want to come to a barbecue
tonight you want to come to a barbecue
we're having a barbecue on the beach on
the beach or the barbecue yet to the
barbecue no come to the barbecue tonight
tonight at the beach cute
you
once it feel like they've shut the
selling record
the whole time the new thing well it's
kind of unbelievable isn't it I can't a
category it's not true
joanne sky 90's icon the tours is great
I know it sometimes even ruining things
after kind of holt
breaking up with my band actually I
think you should just do something else
I decided to enroll in a university out
here just kind of educate myself and go
back to school it seems sort of like a
grown-up decision why never that's why
I'm meant to be here because I meant to
educate them yeah because when women of
experience life experience sexual
experience teaching the fun of life what
are you doing during freshman week of
your rave or some things are rape
tonight probably not my right face let's
go back whoever has sex first gets 50
quid
I've seen your moves and I've seen your
dancing and I think I think there's
based in there got it
yeah I'll be the girl who who gets up on
tables and dances and falls in the face
of that guy yeah I can be be that guy
he's a nice guy
you think you'd enough of you is that
what you're saying there are some good
things that came out of the night
uh yeah like you I don't know I've
always felt like I've just been racing
Racing racing racing to get to what I
don't know it's magic like magic you're
going on with me yeah
[Music]
just keeping the focus you always want
to keep your focus you never take your
eyes off this target hey Joe yeah I
really held back to you if I would have
gotten four she would not have been able
to have children you know one full force
[Music]
you
you